what's up rambley toes is Hannibal
Burres host of the handsome Ranbir
podcast thinking about ditching that
name to be honest I haven't dropped an
episode in a while so with space from
the name I've gotten clarity maybe it's
terrible
who knows anyways we got an episode that
we recorded with JPEG mafia amazing
hip-hop artist we recorded while he was
in Chicago
performing that Pitchfork Music Festival
and I got to watch him do a video with
Jeff sweetie right before we did the
podcast that Tony trans place and so it
was cool to kind of watch somebody do an
interview or play their music for
somebody and then be able to interview
and talk with them immediately
afterwards it was really fun so uh we
were supposed to drop this with his
album all my heroes our corn balls
dropped but we at weirdest organize but
luckily he's at a video drop Frieda
frail is available now and check out the
album all all streaming platforms and
buy it - it's great album great
production and here's the episode Miami
nights coming soon next special yeah
[Music]
is it weird that I started picking up
drinking it 29 last year this year this
year yeah this year I feel like it's
it's it's really late but wait pick it
up like you just you just started
drinking I didn't just it's like I you
know I don't not a consistent drinking
I'm a social right so but I've been
drinking more I've been like more into
the idea of getting drunk as I approach
30 for some reason what uh so ok more in
it meaning you had drank before yeah
I've drunk before I just like but now
you more and said I did for drinks yeah
cuz I was trying to say okay is that is
that rap stress that's exactly what it
is actually tore stress we're with jay
penc my feet on the handsome rambling
podcast
I'm your host Hannibal Buress DJ Tony
trim on the drums
yo so I'm trying to think where to start
with this this drinking thing is really
fascinating drinking habit yeah yeah I
just never was a drinker so I just I was
like I'm in today I want to see what
other people seeing it right cuz usually
I just black out and feel terrible
do you drink before Schultz no
absolutely not
okay I can't do that your shows are
intense
I just been to one but I assume the rest
of them like that so I was at the show
because I was doing gigs in Seattle in
March and I stayed an extra day and
started this staples out of show yeah
and you were supporting on there
and that was uh that was wild man
yeah it was it's uh is fascinating to me
you could have made the choice to be a
cult leader with that energy you make a
lot of eye contact yeah it was uh really
intense the intro was was cold because I
didn't you don't have a DJ no so he
gives up there
boom mess with the laptop and it's very
very subdued and chill and it is me he
bout to be crazy because nobody's just
being that she'll for no reason what is
he up to
and then showed up soon I sue because I
I saw that one the thug tears I like
this this probably translates really
well alive oh yeah yeah don't tears the
colors the colors you had the on beat
spit be spit I did I didn't mean to do
that
really no oh man see sometimes it just
happens now got the all be spit yeah
it's me Jake big mafia I don't have to
prepare to spit on beat
how does a good movement thank you yeah
thank you appreciate that yeah the show
was it was really it was a lot of energy
it is enjoyable too but then it's also
stressful okay yeah what do you need us
to do you feel like that though when you
see like rappers get hype like how do I
translate that with comedy no no no I
mean as a regular person just watching I
like what just in life in general breaks
it this person next to me they better
stop bumping into me no no I'm not
taking a picture with you like take a
picture energy right now do you see
what's going on up there
that's selfie time it's not about me you
see like mosh pits breaking out a lot
yeah yeah all the time that's a that's a
staple mosh pits I usually try to go in
them headfirst also you do to stay you
get crazy with it yeah I'm down in there
there's a lot of since I played
Coachella and in our pitchfork there's a
lot of HD footage of me and mosh pits
which is pretty cool
wow so you gotta like do you feel
pressure that you got a double up and
jump off a higher speakers and do crazy
[ __ ] no [ __ ] no okay good I think I
think I think anything I do that's like
I'm trying too hard yeah purpose I think
people would detect that immediately and
be like call [ __ ] yes I don't even
know it is I I just let the shows be
what they are I just naturally do it do
you have a cardio workout routine to
prep or is the show your workout the
show is kind of the workout but yeah I
do I do some you do boxing don't you
damn how did you know actually yeah yeah
I knew you guys do something where you
hit self stuff that's not it you know
maybe there's some yoga involved but for
recovery is not the primary exercise no
no yogurt just yeah I do do a lot of
boxing yeah that's really it I just try
to stay in shape I don't feel in shape a
lot of times I actually was wearing
corduroys today because I didn't feel my
stomach was - it was too out there today
so corduroys yeah it gets something it
gives cause if I was out there with no
shirt
it would just be gut and then like
shorts gonna be layin had I would have
the overlap thing so like texture he
wanted texture okay I just don't like
that for me I don't like when I watch
that back and I see it good I'll stop
watching it I won't watch the
performance I'll be like I'm good
corduroy and that's when you put asleep
mess the audio performance
yeah I could do that but yeah no I
appreciate that man like my shows are
just I just let him be
yeah damn that was legitimately worried
for you cuz I was just okay this is
Seattle but this is not the only city in
the world this is not a one-off this is
not a one-off special you can't just
send this to everybody do this in
Portland and it was just yeah that's uh
it's uh I know it's tough cause
sometimes during my show though if I
just gotta say a bunch of words together
while walking across the stage then
those next three jokes are gonna suffer
sorry guys boom ooh I didn't prep for
that so I just when I see somebody
really working and and you know in that
opening foursome
so you know I know your fans were
definitely in the building but it's
still somebody else's show so to bring
that and shout out to Vince staples to
devastate us to have somebody that's
bringing it like that before you shows
uh just a level of confidence in his own
show because most passes somebody saw
your show anyway I like your show
I've wish you the best I enjoy your
music but no you can't open for me
damn you think that I I've never I've
never encountered that no I guess I've
seen that so many times where you see
like yeah the way you're like it man's
like yeah where you go to see like the
yeah definitely what music where you go
to see the the main the headline and
then you're just like man had opener was
way better I'm not saying that you know
I'm not saying somebody's better than
somebody but you know if you bring it
you know what I'm saying like you yeah
like he said you got to be super
confident about well yes it's not even
just - bringing it and having a dope so
it's just emotional because I didn't
know every song but I like yep I believe
in this know like way back I saw I saw
wu-tang open for Rage Against the
Machine and I wanted to go see crazy
yeah and I want to go see Rage Against
the Machine
but after whoo tang I was like man I
don't need to see Rage Against the
Machine anymore but they still brought
it I mean it was still a great show but
I think that was the point it's like
we're gonna just give you all kinds of
[ __ ] and we're gonna [ __ ] your head
yeah and the [ __ ] was dope all around
like there were no complaints yeah you
know Sam did uh what was your early
touring experiences touring touring
shows that you know was it always a lot
of energy intensity so so my initial
shows were completely hostile so I was
performing in like butt [ __ ] nowhere
Louisiana
and like you know the tiger-stripe was
some weird ass you know place where they
only do like Metallica cover bands and
[ __ ] so I would just go there they would
let me perform like some songs and then
you know nobody would like it because I
was performing in front of like rednecks
and [ __ ] so after a while I realized
like this woman my career will never
take off while I'm living here so I
began to take it as a joke so like I
would show up and just do hostile [ __ ]
on purpose
oh yeah yeah so I would just show up and
like because I've always kind of rapped
about similar things so I would show up
and just go have the most like most
politically like charged song I could
possibly think of that I know would
offend the crowd just to see their
reaction or like a feeling trolling live
trolling I was just I was trolling them
but in real life and that's why the port
roller was a thing I guess is like it's
late 2010 but then like the worst of it
came when I used to come on stage with
the flag with the Confederate flag yeah
and people would like want to start
fights and [ __ ] so like those are my
initials that's the shows I come from
like originally what would you do to the
flag or lift the flag it was just beat I
mean I would have it so if you know it
was a bath curtain I bought off Amazon
and I I just take it I had I just take
it to shows and be like anybody knows
that like anybody who knows about flags
especially these type of people they
know that you can't do anything with the
flag but fly it straight up anything
else is disrespectful so I just do what
the [ __ ] ever where does a cape run it
through my balls whatever step on it
whatever anything everything I knew that
they couldn't deal with and they weren't
gonna do anything about it now some of
them did something about it but it's
just like you know yeah I'm here what's
up and then I showed up next week doing
the same [ __ ] so it's like I don't know
that's hot that's the first few shows I
did were like that that's you know so
you probably have some research on this
that even if they say it most people
most people don't want to fight no I
mean yeah that's true most people do
most people don't want to fight even if
they
they really date once it gets to it oh
yeah the idea either that or they want
you to throw the first punch but it's
never like I really want to just hurt
somebody cause unless they're a warrior
that'd immediate disadvantage because
you throw in the first or maybe get
pushed or proposed maybe provoke spit on
something like that yeah somebody an
unknown factor just throws the first
punch that's a world of possibilities
sucker punch is the worst feeling have
you ever been sucker-punched yes it's
the worst villain in the world man be
several times tell us about one of the
one of the worst times
I got sucker punch that was I was in
class I forgot this is gonna sound
really weird but I think it was like the
day of 9/11 yeah I was in like history
class oh [ __ ] teacher walked in walk
there was like the Oh
does anybody have family in the World
Trade Center cuz it just got bombed and
then everybody was like no no no and
then I don't know some dude came and
just like clock the [ __ ] out of me like
right after you activate it put me
straight to sleep some weird answer
sounds and I wasn't I wasn't doing
anything I think it was because it like
some it was something to happen earlier
in like too much of but like I just I
wasn't even in that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
knock this [ __ ] out though yeah he did
it he achieved his goal you remember his
name
that's ruin his social media you work in
government who was it you know you are
find out who it is we're talking about
jpg mafia in 20
you know better that is uh I'm back man
let me see he says 21 21 21 who's in
college wait no I wasn't right what at
9/11 cuz I was
oh not 11 I was like Ted or something
yeah yeah so I got knocked out of ten
pretty cleanly yeah I mean it is what it
is I just like Nikki's getting knocked
out it happens
I didn't I don't feel no type of way
about it cuz I wasn't even paying
attention I had no chance to I mean were
you giving off like what what was it
were you giving off like unpatriotic
vibes like say like [ __ ] America before
that happened I said nothing no that's
like happened it happened at lunch
beforehand yeah but we might have been
joking on each other and I got on him
too hard as oh oh he's just so he just
was venting on you yeah man this is New
York City in the nose or the mm ah
because you think he a cop no he
probably is easy the yeah or a security
guard purity got you security guard
vibes yeah Midtown strong cracker bones
did you move back down to North Carolina
you know North Carolina is the south you
get the DC pretty easily you still you
know yeah it's the battery but but every
date yeah I feel like I'm scrolling my
facebook right now yeah that's where
everyone ends up this is some random
state pregnant yeah that's like the
graveyard of like people used to know
Facebook it's like the living graveyard
yes I am this is what you've been for
the past ten years
yeah Dan where are you still working at
Foot Locker this is what yeah this is
why you're not on Instagram because your
life ain't fly you got [ __ ] to talk
about
it's writing on Facebook yeah yeah yeah
just real [ __ ] but yeah those are my
shoes
oh those are my shows and that's the
time I got knocked the [ __ ] out at that
age will you
doing any performance in school were you
in plays did you have a little hip-hop
group of other like-minded kids no at
that age I had a group of friends who we
all know we all like did similar [ __ ]
like listening to music different kinds
of music is [ __ ] but no at the time none
of us wanted to be rappers anything we
just enjoyed music it wasn't until like
two years later when I started making
beats that I was like [ __ ] I gotta do
music but like I always liked I always
loved music but like it wasn't till I
was like 14 and I was like I have to do
music I was like a hack I got to do it
just like this is the only thing I could
do did you an open mike eagle bond
because you both don't use DJ's that's
like I think I think more and more MCS
Iran that these days I'd be seeing
though yeah the no DJ thing or no hype
man
- no hype man if you if you got it then
you got it no hype man and you'd be out
of breath hey get a hype man like daddy
bug juice always have a hype man you
don't like I last like three times what
seemed to me to have a hype man and he's
perfectly fine I was in I was it I was
in I was in Danny Brown's test tell
Scylla Tesla
oh oh you cuz you did the last bruise at
Thanksgiving right yeah yeah I think I
went to his crib and he ordered like
hello White Castle like just like a
hundred burgers
how many for Thanksgiving okay he does
like a annual Thanksgiving parties um he
does a show
one of the legendary venues out there in
Detroit yeah and yeah he brings a few
people in the town and it's a big show
bruza Thanksgiving did they all get
finished
I'm a very waist conscious person okay
hey shout out to Danny Brown for proper
planning yeah being able to get a group
how much food to order because you know
I've misjudged that let me tell you how
I got onto jpgs music okay I just popped
on I was somehow gone banking to find a
music mm-hmm VanCamp all I know they
they give artists a better cut than
everywhere else right yeah yeah yeah if
you listen go to band camp and fine just
look at it genre just check out some
stuff you'll find some rhythm something
you never find on the Spotify Zoar the
items you know you'll find some random
[ __ ] there's this really dope and so I
went on the hip hop list a new hip hop
and I think this is the day is Calvert
yeah 15:39 North Calvert yeah 15:39
North Calvert and so I started listening
so I say this is dope and so did I
download it I pay for it and then you
know you put in your email so he gets
the I guess he got the email yeah and
then he you know he tweeted you know I
burst he put my email up sweater who
trolling me and he's are you putting put
up the screenshot I think yeah bro like
a man what the [ __ ]
can't I support and private music yeah I
mean that's a legit concerned are you
probably like messing with me somebody's
trouble Aviv I just thought there was no
way they still bought the music but help
you write it out and that was your point
in the deal that's why I felt bad when I
read the DM I was like ah damn he's got
somebody went out of their way to get
that name locked out beforehand credit
card info I just man I was a paranoid
[ __ ] even know what I don't even know
what I was scared of I was just like
there's no way that's happened right
where people like have guessed that you
have an email person Gmail and just hit
you wrecked like randomly I think I
think he says them like that before I
would use my email so what what you
gonna do about it
email me [ __ ] you I can read I delete it
I take in useless information all the
time
you think I'm [ __ ] scared of you
email the [ __ ] out of me just cuz I
stuff you got our strict [ __ ] I've
read all types of stuff what are you
gonna do say you're gonna murder me on
the internet I've read that too alive
hey hey hey hey
does a man
that's my email you can hit me up I
haven't changed that [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] that's where I booked my flight
says where I put my phone that's why I
did it on that's where I get the HOS
email me and have a bird at gmail.com
actually when I hope email me there I'll
be like this don't feel right actually
hit me an i G with all your hos behavior
and come to the gig I won't save you I
might get you a flight to Grand rabbit
and then afterwards we'll get it crack
it in the Best Western then I go to my
real hotel and you can sleep over there
kids you can sneak asleep over is this
won't be a long-term thing but you just
really nice to each other for a few days
but then apologize I apologize but
making it blurry like that my bad
I was I see how you thought this was
going somewhere you like my new drum
loops man thanks Doug I'm a working on
was fun so incredible had a really
unexpected evening because uh you were
over at Jeff's Wheaties loft in studio
you say you'll plant him to have them oh
yeah and I go over there just to just to
hear the album but then you all filming
just had a long convalescence on the new
album sounds great yeah thank you it was
great man it's some of his more I guess
yes some stuff more subdued some smooth
[ __ ] in there
but it was it was it was really
it was it was cool [ __ ] man I was
excited to hear that it was bad no it
wasn't bad you know I'm okay just to
bring it back when you said Tweety's
earlier I was just like that's the first
thing at Google is I go to [ __ ] his
Tweety's yeah thought it was like yeah
and then first thing babylons that was
like talking about Jeff Tweedy is like
will : I don't think so oh yeah but I'm
like he is Chicago is [ __ ] so there's
a chance there probably it's Hannibal he
knows everyone there's a chance there at
Jeff Teague Tweety's just hanging out
which I should have just went to by
default so how do you like what I mean
this to me I'm just still like
processing all this out of [ __ ] well I'm
just a fan of them in general I like a
legendary Chicago bad yeah legendary man
you know first I the first song I heard
from them was Jesus etc and yeah what
the [ __ ] is the excellent song so now I
checked out the album that was on love
the album I love that made it after that
that's yeah that's all for Yankee Hotel
box Jerry yeah yeah it's the one that um
came out early two-thousands or so
really fire album and think they just
said like a tight band I love Star Wars
I love like a lot of the albums I just I
have a lot of respect for him I forgot
how we link I think it was on Instagram
I think I made a list or something of
like my favorite albums and one of the
album's is on there and you might have
followed me there I don't remember or
maybe he made a list and I was on it
something like that yeah but that's how
we initially linked that's dope man
yes no cuz you guys seem like such a you
know like unusual couple of friends but
that's dope that you guys just got
together by a music oh yeah I mean with
the music I think anybody who loves
music I can vibe for anyone who loves
music everyone yeah that's just all I do
all day so yeah I think I knew would be
like nothing yeah but like yeah it was
tight he's cool guy he's [ __ ] fire
man he has so much equipment I could
tell you probably nerds out with the
gear I know exactly what you're talking
about a lot of synthesized acts just
like not music just like a chopping axe
twice you don't have to keep doing it
just loop it just looking for different
exons you saying you you talked about
liking lists a lot yeah love lists yeah
I'm a big fan of lists
you should do a TV show is that this
shows already caught the list right the
list whatever
yeah just list just different lists yeah
I would nice to do that that's would be
the lead-up to the album just me doing a
male friend Network yeah different type
of list
[Music]
welcome to the list it's the list top
ten no maybe top six or just top eight
who knows
do you have you said what are your
what's the aspirations for this out is
that bass braces yeah they I mean beyond
you know bigger audience right bigger
audience bigger gigs level Oh Netflix
movie soundtrack placement I would love
that I would love to do a the soundtrack
for a Jennifer Aniston movie for sure
the full soundtrack like like you talk
about scoring til my rapping - oh the
whole shebang not just scoring I would
like to score a movie or like a video
game or something yeah but um for this
album I don't know I I wanted to just
capture something I didn't capture
before which was just me and raw form so
it just sounds like a demo right it's
just not it's just not filtered or
edited in any way well so I just yeah
it's just basically like a big demo this
is the first time I've talked about it
like and not been trolling yeah
so it's got an interesting what's your
troll angle for the album that is
disappointing you tell he was
disappointed
yeah it's disappointing it's uh home to
me to you and possibly to the people
right that's a great strategy because if
you tell people that it's whacked and
then you can only go up from oh it is
way but if you tell them is dope they're
gonna be like this [ __ ] was whack yeah
yeah exactly you can only go up so
that's a good strategy
yeah lower look you have to lower the
expectations so that you get a fair
judgement what's up I liked music
besides being a comedian and podcast
host I'm a fledgling marketing guru and
I have some ideas you got some ideas
what you get one okay you take your your
most hype song
and then you just go push it to boxing
jams that's that you know what hold on
before you laugh before you laugh that's
actually an excellent
I mean if run the jewels did that like
right off jump they'd be like the
hottest gym workout tape in the world
take a lot that's the hole in the gym
and say hey it's easier to get in a
radio station to play that's real [ __ ]
they open the playlist up because they
just yeah yeah okay yeah we played you
still yeah we're a little stagnant we
playing at Travis Scott again but I
don't know come in with fresh energy
[ __ ] what is this
okay that's the thing in the gym
productivity levels go up memberships go
up people are buffer you know what I'm
saying all because of your music man
that's real [ __ ] you with yes you're the
buff guy bro you like people buff now
you have all these boxing aficionados
not at posting video song after video
okay you come you compile the ten best
of those videos hey I got a list for you
guys yes yes yes and then you get the TV
show then you say hey Jennifer Aniston
this is why I just do the soundtrack to
your next movie I have organic
engagement real friends and I'm played
in boxing gyms all across the
continental United States and Alaska we
haven't quite penetrated Hawaii
it's a weird market they like the more
slow stuff but this is obvious
attraction let's work together baby
that's excellent you ever watch that
show Nathan for you yeah it sounds like
like because some of the episodes
they're crazy ideas that
actually worked and I feel like this is
one of those like it's a crazy that I
gotta hit the boxing gym you find a
chain you have one they put it in all
the playlists all those teachers plan if
you want to have fresh stuff they
actually do you know my pitch aside I go
to this gym rumble boxing in LA and so
they're all about promoting the
instructors you know I think they'll
have this screen up you know screen up
with their Instagram and he's after send
me songs to justice blah blah blah so
it's a man this is a wide open market as
far as its really pushing because I
remember I don't know how effective this
is there's only 30 people in each class
I just thought this through
well yeah you gotta film them know you
gotta get actors to act like they really
got transformed by this and then have
them punch bricks Wow
break something really impossible to
break now yeah you gotta have like
visual results it puts the music on the
pedestal because people associated with
dislike power yeah it's like an energy
drink
it's excellent branding is this extra
branding guy yeah your [ __ ] music
makes people pop I actually do this I
just want to know what your reaction
would be if I actually hit the boxing
circuit and was just like and I and it
worked what if it worked
I would I would say yeah yeah it seems
if I feel like it would work on some
level because people yeah this is this
is really about execution and it does
it's not that far off
it just sounds crazy because I sort of
joking but as I if I change tone
I'm thinking I'm like listen to you like
this is an excellent night right now now
let me I'll pitch it like how the music
has a lot of people just get pumped up
when I hear it and so you want to
channel that into this market and so we
have these boxing gyms you've gone these
boxing gyms and it's just you know riped
with viral moments and we just focus on
that and we just grow from there so
here's the strategy different song
that's so scary the accurate it's like I
sound like the whole music industry and
delivery I mean I'll be honest with you
like I've been I've been getting back
into like just working out like I like
that I don't like that like run and jog
and stuff I like to just kind of lift
weights and work like do push-ups and
pull-ups yeah and when I do that should
I like to listen to heavy like metal ass
music like loud good music like that so
great I like to listen to Kate Bush when
I work out really yeah see like I try I
tried to just listen to inspiring stuff
and just whatever type stuff but I need
like just instrumental metal no lyrics
just metal oh you did they have delays
getting away sometimes yeah I like just
like loud just guitars and crashing
drums and like and I'm better I'm way
more effective like usually takes me an
hour to get to my workout but if I play
some like good metal 30 minutes 45 tops
you know if you give them some heavy get
some heavy [ __ ] with so yes hard as
beats no you can give them words no I
got you know I got some stuff with no
words I don't have to say be saying
things every now every time yeah it's
like there's no rule that says I have to
it's true but I my favorite track off of
the North Calvert is the I can't [ __ ]
wait until Morrissey that's the name of
the song that's the name of song I can't
wait in some wars he dies and you don't
like the Smiths
No
and you know what I didn't even and
here's what I'll tell you about I think
the title is great
I know Morrissey he says some racist
[ __ ] in the fans right or something he's
done a plethora of things but III can
definitely explain my vitriol towards
him yeah so I discovered Morrissey or
discovered his racist aura when he made
like a shirt he made this shirt with
James Baldwin's face on it and it said
like around James Baldwin's face I said
I feel black on the inside cuz I'm black
on the outside or some [ __ ] oh I was
just like what the hell kind of white
man would put this on his shirt and then
I cou put it online let's go yeah so
like I just began to look into him and I
realized he's been doing [ __ ] like this
for years I mean that's bold as [ __ ] is
like that's I'm saying because like
there's a layer of just like awareness
that most white people even if they are
like it like that yeah be like no I'm
not gonna put this online
[ __ ] like like he sent it to his [ __ ]
decoded that [ __ ] you know [ __ ] crazy
though you know he actually he's
actually racist and crazy I just started
to look into him and I realized like
people have been letting it go because
he makes good music or he makes music
that you know affects them and affects
people in some way that they don't want
to let that go so there's a well-known
thing cuz I've never heard of this
before
it's not a well-known thing that's well
known to me because I saw that [ __ ] and
I was like [ __ ] what the hell are you
doing
but then uh but yeah so he became more
of like a symbol of like people who
claim they're like about all these
issues but then they like let this [ __ ]
just do whatever I saw a list of top ten
controversial Morrissey sayings I'm just
like you made a top ten that means you
pick 30 cycle through this you a logical
mean you're the cool so that so that's
why I'm just like that's why I was going
that's why I'm at that point I realized
that I made that song cuz I was just
like you [ __ ] just keep letting him
slide and then you know whatever it
rhiannon recently he wore like a racist
pin on like Jimmy Fallon as well oh [ __ ]
he's racing I don't know some like
racist party in it I got a I forgot but
it's kind of a low-key those super and
then everybody was like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] racist and I was just like [ __ ]
what what the [ __ ] it took a pin for you
to realize this [ __ ] my [ __ ]
I like yo it yeah that's really what my
my issue with him it's like I don't
Morris he's not really worth a piece of
garbage to me it's more like what he
represents I don't actually guess I mean
I get I guess it's it's interesting to
hear your point because I've never was
like the biggest Smith's fan like I know
a couple of songs but you must have been
a really big fan to really point that
out at one point I almost feel like
really respected him oh yeah yeah yeah I
listen to this album hat full of hollow
and I was like yo this [ __ ] got some
jammers on it yeah so like you know I
got to my knowledge of the Smiths I
didn't know much outside of that but
like my real introduction to him was
that [ __ ] shirt and I was just like
who the [ __ ] made this shirt and put it
online for sale yeah I can't I'm gonna
add this to my car right now this is a
real thing he did so I was just like
yeah anyone who got to the point where
they feel like they okay it's okay to do
that yeah must be so far gone for so
long that [ __ ] just letting it happen
so I just peep game real fast as soon as
I saw the shirt I was like who's
responsible and yeah that's my that's
the that's the origin of my issue with
him okay what shifted my Pino Morsy and
I kind of saw the song itself song still
dope the song so was it a choice to make
the beat kind of like Hello yo game beat
I wanted I wanted to beat that people
like there's like it's just like real
catchy and simple yeah I was just like
cool this is the beat no I didn't this
is what I didn't articulate that right
I'll say I can't
I knew that Morrissey was racist but I
didn't I guess I didn't listen to the
Smiths enough for that to really this is
like oh why do they may come soon as may
or may not like black house owners now
do okay play pour some sugar on me some
other white power ballad that's a good
point is not like it's not something
anyone is obligated to care about I'm
just I'm just in a field where I see a
lot of people yeah together me that's
the only reason I'm responding well
that's respectful that's respectful but
no I've listened to that song 15 20
times in a row before in the whip was a
deeper song for you I knew what he was
saying for Z but it was the song itself
again bleeps on there yeah i bleeped it
out from so like i bleep so there's a
line I was I said white boys i bleeped
out boys yeah because people get
sensitive so I'm just like let me just
let me let me let me let me let me curb
that for you you know say let me make
that song wait why do people get
sensitive about the word boys no it's
not it's the context it's just I'm doing
it to be like sarcastic because I'm just
like they listen to they listen to
people they listen to [ __ ] talking
about killing each other all day right
but as soon as I turned that lens on
them then [ __ ] can't handle it for one
song right like for one song it's like I
can't take it sob I blocked it out as a
joke I blocked out
as a joke sometimes I block out cracker
200 you can't handle it's like artistic
old I like that that's though ya know
yeah exactly sometimes outright a verse
yeah and I have like [ __ ] I'm about to
kill you I'll just like switch it to
cracker if I can I just switch I just
switch it because I just like I know
like most people won't notice it but
people who are like races will pick up
on it and be like why are you saying
this bro you know what's up
it forces them to reveal themselves it's
like yeah um what's what you may call it
did something similar
um Paul Mooney he did something like
racial testing or something just do like
certain things to like make people like
wait a minute
bla bla bla and it'll make me like oh I
know what you're about now got it but
you know you know it's funny back in the
days I remember like when Snoop Dog's
doggy style came out they had they had
the day of the drop the n-word backwards
all the time but you know what it was
because you could hear it me like sayin
see you could hear it you know what I'm
saying so it's like I know what he said
it's just backwards right so like maybe
you should do that with crackers and be
like riprap you don't have Sam like that
could be because don't know that you're
saying crackers but it'd be like
rickrack I'm mad that you you imitated
[ __ ] backwards so perfectly now I
wanted if when I put it in there I
wanted to be on purpose it's for a
reason yeah I'm literally like I'm
literally poking at these people on
purpose yes don't say what they mean
ever yeah yeah
all kind of [ __ ] they'll never say I'm
racist and I don't like you cuz you're
black or I don't like you cuz whatever
you're you're from the Middle East I
don't [ __ ] with that there instead of
saying that they'll wrap it up in
anything else it'll be about they just
if they play a lot of mental gymnastics
like the Colin Kaepernick [ __ ] mm-hm I
was in the military I never seen none of
them [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about the flag
until that [ __ ] started kneeling and
then all of a sudden they were like wait
a minute and I'm just like it is what it
is if all [ __ ] decided
start swimming they would have a problem
with pools all of a sudden like they
just don't they don't say what they mean
ever so I'm just like this is the only
way I can get them to tell the truth yes
with the capper dick thing to and and
him kneeling during yeah you know it's a
huge football stadiums are huge
there's absolutely people like buying
concessions I know it's not real that's
I was losing [ __ ] [ __ ] we do all kind
of hellish like way worse than I knew it
as soon as I saw that I was like that's
not what y'all that's that I can't be is
definitely somebody thousand people man
yeah someone's definitely [ __ ] Mattie's
[ __ ]
but still a lot of people are drunk from
[ __ ] tailgating yeah somebody's on
the fly yeah falling around throwing up
that's very disrespectful he's gritting
their teeth did you uh so what do you do
quit this cuz your show you have a lot
of crowd interaction yeah do you ever
that person but show must go on
is what it is literally every time I
perform you know if you watch any of my
shows there's there's usually a point
where I hit somebody wrong or something
I'm just like I literally I'll just
apologize like an idiot that but like
you're my bad I apologize I try to keep
it I like my shows to be you know my
shows get hectic but I like for there to
be like I'm not like trying to make you
yell [ __ ] beat each other for no
reason like be safe or whatever but yeah
do whatever you want yeah I feel like
people pay money they can do it no I
think people know who you are and what
they're getting when they come
see you I don't think you worry about
that you just need to go out there and
do your [ __ ] thing and not worry
about these [ __ ] goddamn princesses
do the goddamn show of the show today
and it was I I would sleep during actual
set because I'm a bit jet-lagged so my
schedules off I got gone I don't know
but the live stream being there felt
good
felt like solid research consisted
different angles versus is being in a
mix or side stage or whatever I don't
know but it was a one point where you
went into the crowd and it was kind of
cool to see cuz they there was no
security with you know there was no
barricades at this point but it was
split it was it was a clear split this
old trailer you had to work with people
were hyped they were like we need we
need to give him his room when normally
you know people that kind of get around
artists it's just yeah it was a clear I
didn't plan it like that usually when I
part people like that yeah they used to
just swarm me and I'm just like let me
just fight it find it out yeah but ya
had so much room I was like cool I just
thought I'd do my thing I was like this
is great I can do this what's the last
time you did an afternoon show because
people aren't drunk probably people
aren't on the drugs yeah I mean yeah but
it takes start day of a festival also
know for sure but not yet the Soul Train
line was fine it was really good it was
really interesting I didn't I was
surprised by it but it was a pleasant
surprise and then eventually they kind
of like kind of just tried to gather in
but not really and then I just went back
onstage I was ok what's what's your live
show when you watching other rappers
what's your live show pet peeve pet
peeve yeah cuz you got a very specific
show you work on
you give y'all a lot of energy so I'm
sure you have specific critiques when
you see a show that's actually excellent
I got a lot but yeah my so my critique
my only critique is just laziness like
if you're not putting effort into it
yeah it doesn't really matter what
they're doing is obvious that's the
problem with it yeah I don't like
laziness and like rapping over your own
vocals I mean rapping over your vocals
even that I don't really mind that you
know cuz like you know for example like
I've seen trippy red live and he raps
over his own vocals but it's [ __ ]
crazy like he's like he's out there
dying like he takes off his shirt he'd
be sweating he's like he's given a
[ __ ] performance you know saying but
I feel like just I'm talking about just
rapping on your mixtape and doing a
half-ass all yeah yet that's
specifically what I'm saying yeah
walking back and forth yeah I really
cared about the crowd or antagonizing
the crowd being like [ __ ] y'all oh I got
paid already and [ __ ] pisses me off I'm
just like [ __ ] really like people these
people up paying your bills you know
that in like you don't have to like bow
down to him but like why come out and
openly disrespect them for no reason
yeah so I guess that's my only pet
peeves cuz like I've seen all kinds of
great shows I've seen people stand
completely still and like have the whole
crowd going bro yeah I've seen crazy
[ __ ] like yeah yeah so my only pet peeve
is just laziness I guess I think too
with music with rap music especially one
or two songs can change something yes so
fast where somebody now is a big touring
artist but they had they had no time to
really get stripes so now to meet the
demand and get the money while I was
there they do any shows but they it was
no you know they weren't in no rapper
camp and you know and so then they get
out there and this is a bit too early
yeah now that that definitely happens
ooh yeah cuz it's some time where I've
seen people I'd rather hear the song
I'd rather hit a song and hang out I'd
put on some [ __ ] animation muted mm
instead of watching you right now no
that's that that is true man that that
like there's been so many rappers where
I'm just like this is way better when I
deejay this [ __ ] rather than here and
you do it live your live [ __ ] is trash
and that's crazy because there should be
a hundred times better cuz it's live
[ __ ] you go home yeah I've never ever
want to give that feeling no even if
someone thinks my performance is bad I
want them to at least know I put all the
effort yeah or cancel if you just can't
do it just cancel like would you
wouldn't you rather just do that then
give somebody a a totally lackluster
show what cancel on what notice like you
got [ __ ] what a meningitis laryngitis
notice you try fighting you're drinking
a lot of teeth you know you did your
best
everybody yeah I really had the
situation where my book I could
literally couldn't do a show cuz my
voice was too shot yeah and not be like
I put a statement out of my Instagram
like hey my bad can't do this show I
will make it up though and literally
have [ __ ] be in my DMS like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you hate your throat yeah like [ __ ] like
that like just like on some like you
know whatever I don't give a [ __ ] so
like it happens like that sometimes with
what network that is saved and then wait
until your throat heals and then yell at
them full voice chamomile tea [ __ ] you
that's it damn you know you just [ __ ]
internalize it but you probably have
your friends I imagine my lot I mean
it's the Internet in general people say
wild [ __ ] yeah just to get a reaction
then you react they say
[Music]
that's actually what it sounds like
audio yeah everyone who do that they're
just like a [ __ ] turkey as their life
just yeah they're just like that I'm
just trying to get a reaction out of you
right yeah that that rarely on the
internet it's it I don't want to just
say this because it probably jinx it I
don't even gonna say it but like it's
just like it's very difficult for
someone to get a reaction in that way
from me like you know what I mean like
try harder type [ __ ] you know that's
another problem with like these internet
races troll types they don't know the
humor doesn't evolve they laugh at the
same [ __ ] for years and like it doesn't
think their tactics are all the same it
is what it is but yeah you feel me
yeah me okay we're gonna wrap this up
what's up yep
and so I feel like that can be that
could be taught well it could be coached
you for promo for a new album
coaching young kiddie rappers on live
stage before that would be interesting
to say the least and then you know
because they say when you teach that's
what I learned
yeah you learn again because you teach
it and so that's really you learned
deeper when you teach that's what I was
told from my kung-fu teacher
you know I never I never thought that
it's not I don't know if I would be able
to teach what I'm doing because I'm not
it's just something you I'm doing I'm
not really yeah so that's the angle is
that you know you've been kind of pushed
into this role as teacher you're
resentful of it kids this is a comedy
sketch kids you know you get frustrated
with the kids throw them out
what and just think this is fun fun
promo stuff man
Toby father have you had any mentors in
the industry or people that have helped
you a lot um yeah there's been a few
people I'd say flu you know flu yeah the
producer yeah it's great I would say flu
I wouldn't I don't know if it's a really
a mentor thing I feel from floom but
it's more like I'm talking to someone
who is very skilled and I can like you
know learn from right he's working with
like everyone his work had been say
Bulls you know charli XCX great yeah
he's amazing producer very technically
skilled you know um but mentors not
really there's a guy from from Baltimore
who is one of my favorite rappers and
influence which means name is Abdul Ali
but that's probably the closest I would
say to a mentor other than that and I'm
just I'm out here [ __ ] up and making
mistakes alone man thank you for joining
us on the show yeah honestly it's an
honor like thank you so much I've seen
your Netflix a lot of times I seen you
own nothing no I've been holding it in
like I'm like literally it didn't like
really settle into it because I was like
talking to Jeff Tweedy like in like
playing the album oh but like as I'm
sitting here talking it's like yeah I'm
honored you sitting at the laptop on a
couch Jeff sweetie times right yeah
and then ate one of me sit to the left I
was kind of set but who's telling you
what what's going on no there's just
like a camera guys hell you want to sit
there and I was gonna stand and all
everything is set to the left behind his
laptop it felt like disingenuous
position positioning just met this guy
can't just be over here looking at him
checking as he's planning music spite
that a good friend where of you and then
they said sit down so I got comfortable
sat back down but excited foot to hit a
full project excited about what I heard
and much success man keep it gangsta all
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's our noise ban we got a noise
[Music]